I would,
Lauren asks,
I would love to hear you do a lecture
series on raising children properly.
Is that something you would consider?
Well,
in my new book,
I've written a chapter on that called
don't let your children do anything that
makes you dislike them.
And I've laid out a bunch of,
uh,
I've laid out a philosophy of care and
discipline that's predicated partly on a
French philosophical legal notion,
which is do not multiply
rules beyond necessity.
It's sort of like illegal equivalent to
all comes razor and an English common
law principle is which is
used minimal necessary force.
And I think the Union of those two,
which is don't have too many rules,
but make sure that you properly enforced
the ones that you do have is a good
start for how you might consider your
attitude with regards to raising children.
The other thing you have to figure
out is exactly what's your aim.
And you know,
one of the aims that people have
had most recently pushed by clueless
psychologists,
I would say,
is that you want children
to have high self esteem.
And uh,
that's actually a large part trait.
Neuroticism anyways,
but by,
and it can be modified to some degree.
Jerome Kagan has done some
very interesting work on that.
But,
um,
the best thing to do,
I think the best thing to orient yourself
towards with regards to children is
that you're trying to make your child,
your children or help your children to
be delightful in the eyes of others.
And so that means they have to
be reasonably well socialized.
And that really takes place
between the ages of two and four.
Because what you want for your children
is that when they go out into public,
when they're away from you or
even with you for that matter,
what you want for your children is for
other people to genuinely like them.
Because if they behave reasonably and
they attend properly to adults and they
know how to play with other children,
then wherever they go,
they're going to be,
um,
unless they encountered
someone truly malevolent,
they're going to be welcomed
with smiles and open arms.
And that's not going to be fake because
almost every human being actually likes
children if they're reasonably behaved.
And so your job is to make your children
highly socially desirable because that
opens up the world to them.
So they're,
that's not a lecture series,
but it's a little lecture.